hello this YouTube channel so I haven't
put up a video here for a while remember
I made that crazy idea promised that I
would put one up every Saturday it
didn't happen I let you down you can't
rely on me and that's the trust level
that we've established for each other so
that makes me sad but what doesn't make
me sad is that there are that what
talking makes me sad there are some
really exciting things happening soon
really excited anything's happening that
I think you would be really it would
benefit you if you checked out those
really exciting things there starting
Monday October 11 2010 and you can just
go just go yeah for your own benefit you
should check it out for yourself it'll
be a funny discovery you I like dancing
what else did I have a story for you
today I don't think I did
oh I had a dream the other night I had
so many dreams happening that it was it
was crazy but at one point in the dream
I was in this auditorium waiting for
this speech or event to happen and the
entire Cosby family was sitting in front
of me but it was Bill Cosby's like
real-life family and I got my phone out
to take a picture to put it on my blog
cuz even in my dreams I'm concerned with
blogging that's telling but anyway all
of his family members had his face so
was just a series of Bill Cosby's in
different clothes and different like
body shapes and sizes but all Bill Cosby
faces so I couldn't figure out which is
the real Bill Cosby and I didn't want to
put the wrong bill cost
on my blog and I tried to ask someone
which one of those people is Bill Cosby
and I and then it morphed into something
else I think it morphed into bingo after
that and then some other funny stuff
happen but yeah so that's been on my
mind what does that mean
who knows that I don't recognize
I don't recognize people's faces I I
don't know but anyway this has been fun
thanks for listening this YouTube
channel you guys are cool bye